bueno
ah
[Música]
bienvenidos a esta emisión de en
exclusivo desde la ciudad de los ángeles
donde se celebra la novena cumbre de las
américas y en el marco de este encuentro
del hemisferio me abre espacio en su
agenda al presidente de guyana el doctor
mohammed y alí presidente muchas gracias
por acompañarnos en france 24 y
bienvenidos a esta emisión especial
gracias
presidente y cuál es el papel de guyana
en la cumbre
igual por su vida en pareja pitt el
examen es parte de caricom
en primer lugar estoy muy contento de
estar en esta cumbre como parte del
equipo de la caricom tenemos una serie
de cuestiones que hemos identificado que
deben abordarse en el marco del tema de
la cumbre que es la sostenibilidad la
resiliencia y la construcción de un
futuro que traiga prosperidad a todos
los habitantes de esta región en la
cumbre hay una serie de áreas que son
críticas para nosotros en los ámbitos
del cambio climático los servicios
medioambientales la delincuencia
transnacional la seguridad alimentaria
la seguridad energética estas son las
áreas clave para nosotros como saben
guyana ha estado desempeñando un rol
destacado en la cuestión del cambio
climático tenemos una selva del tamaño
de inglaterra que almacena 19 5
gigatoneladas de carbono también
buscamos un desarrollo equilibrado
además somos uno de los nuevos países en
el sector del petróleo y el gas nuestros
recursos son de 11 mil millones de
barriles y la exploración sigue en
marcha por tanto lo que nos gustaría ver
en esta conferencia es una serie de
temas a los que se enfrentan los países
en vías de desarrollo lo que requiere no
sólo un debate concreto sino un
calendario factible a través del cual
podamos alcanzar este tipo de objetivos
nos ayudarán a construir la
sostenibilidad es el nombre jesús
en cuanto a ser fiestas rituales anotó
un y concluido discusión han accionado
time frame which we can
vivimos en un mundo en vías de
desarrollo sólo para la mitigación del
cambio climático necesitamos cerca de
300.000 millones de dólares anuales de
dónde saldrán esos recursos vivimos en
una región las américas en la que sigue
habiendo una gran disparidad en la que
hay disparidad de ingresos disparidad
financiera disparidad social brechas en
sectores importantes como la educación
la atención sanitaria y todas son
cuestiones que deben abordarse para
construir un futuro que sea resiliente
que garantice que creemos un equilibrio
estado
bondad en su balance
la cuestión de la seguridad alimentaria
también es un reto importante para la
región especialmente desde la pandemia y
ahora con la guerra en ucrania entonces
lo que me gustaría que saliera de la
cumbre básicamente es un plan de acción
para abordar todas estas cuestiones no
sólo un compromiso sino un compromiso
seguido de nuestra capacidad y nuestra
confianza para poner plazos a varias de
las iniciativas que debatiremos en la
conferencia
and finance en time line en ambas
naciones
el destino de guyana cambió en 2015 con
el hallazgo de pozos de petróleo en el
fondo del mar cómo se ha avanzado cómo
se ha ido avanzando en la extracción de
este petróleo
ah
va excepcionalmente bien tomamos un
camino en el que estamos persiguiendo
agresivamente la exploración y llevando
esas exploraciones a la producción como
he dicho tenemos un recurso probado de
11.000 millones de barriles ahora para
cuando lleguemos a 2025 deberíamos estar
produciendo cerca de un millón de
barriles diarios también
aparte
significa gris
savant así que eso aumentará
significativamente los flujos de
ingresos y para 2000 27 ó 28 esa cifra
debería llegar a 1,2 millones de
barriles diarios en cuanto a la
producción y exploración hemos visto una
aceleración hemos visto un buen progreso
y también en cuanto al medio ambiente
hemos reforzado la legislación ahora
tenemos una multa por quema de gases
tenemos un mejor sistema de control
estamos construyendo la capacidad de
recursos humanos y en cuanto a la
transparencia ya la gobernanza hemos
mejorado nuestro marco nuestro fondo
nacional de recursos ahora tenemos una
junta independiente que gestionará ese
fondo todos los recursos que entran en
el fondo deben ser declarados
públicamente en el plazo determinado por
el ministro de finanzas y su
incumplimiento puede acarrear la cárcel
así que desde la perspectiva de la
gobernanza la perspectiva institucional
la perspectiva medioambiental y la
perspectiva de la producción hemos
tenido un enorme desarrollo y avance
en su sucio
no había tecnología para extraer el
crudo como se ha ido trabajando en esto
cómo se ha construido y hay
participación de otros países en la
extracción
así es
exxon
bueno como saben este proceso comenzó
con un consorcio esta exxon tenemos
otros bloques petroleros también tenemos
todas las exploraciones en marcha por
xix y xx' y así sucesivamente
hay otros bloques nos hemos comprometido
a algunas cosas una es examinar la
posibilidad de una compañía petrolera
nacional y dos la subasta de los bloques
restantes así que estamos finalizando
nuestra evaluación en términos del curso
que tomaremos si tendremos una subasta
completa de los bloques petroleros o si
pasaremos al desarrollo de una compañía
petrolera nacional como parte de la
solución así es como estamos avanzando
en esto
the national complete es parte auto
solución
advanced
presidente en que se está invirtiendo el
dinero de la extracción del petróleo
en qom somos un país que tiene una renta
per cápita de unos 6000 dólares y
estamos en el continente americano y
podemos hacer una comparación cruzada
tenemos la responsabilidad de asegurar
que el dinero haga algunas cosas uno
mejorar el nivel de la vida de la gente
de nuestro país 2 crear nuevas
oportunidades de empleo hacer que
nuestra economía sea competitiva ampliar
lo mayor de nuestra economía fortalecer
otros sectores y 3 garantizar que haya
suficiente reserva en el sistema para
las generaciones futuras y en los tres
frentes estamos abordando esta cuestión
1 no podemos tener acceso a los recursos
ya que la gente no tenga las mejores
instalaciones posibles hemos dejado muy
claro que queremos invertir en una
asistencia sanitaria primaria de
categoría mundial para los habitantes de
nuestro país
word
for
the world education vamos a invertir
enormemente en educación para tener una
educación de categoría mundial en
infraestructuras viarias en
infraestructuras de transporte en el
costo de la electricidad que queremos
reducir a la mitad el panorama general
de las infraestructuras del país será
transformado buscamos una combinación de
energías que incluye el gas natural la
hidroelectricidad la eólica y la solar
para acercarnos a una huella 100%
renovable así es como estamos avanzando
estamos invirtiendo muchos recursos
humanos estamos trabajando en la
competitividad de nuestro sector
agrícola porque queremos convertirnos no
solo en un gran actor en el sector
petrolero y el gas sino que queremos
convertirnos en un actor aún mayor en el
sistema alimentario de la región
y todos estos planes ya están en marcha
o los dispersaran sin transmisión
procesos privados
todos estos planes están en marcha el
proceso de transformación ya comenzó la
mejora de los diferentes sectores para
hacerlos más competitivos ya comenzó el
plan de expansión del empleo ya comenzó
los planes para reducir el costo de la
energía a la mitad para estimular la
inversión en la manufactura y el
desarrollo industrial eso ya empezó el
costo del proyecto de mejorar la salud y
la educación ya comenzó el proyecto de
transformación de nuestras
infraestructuras también comenzó y hasta
ahora no hemos tocado ni un solo centavo
de los ingresos procedentes del petróleo
de caso la otra cosa es que siempre
hemos mantenido nuestras credenciales en
materia de medio ambiente
tenemos un bosque en pie que vale 400
mil millones de dólares el tamaño de
inglaterra y nuestro flujo de ingreso
anual que puede provenir del carbono es
de unos 200 millones de dólares pero el
hecho es que eso no es suficiente porque
el fmi por ejemplo dice que para que
alcancemos los 2 grados centígrados es
necesario que el precio del carbono sea
de 75 dólares hoy está entre 3 y 6
dólares así que entendemos la
importancia de los ingresos siempre
hemos tenido un enorme potencial en
todos los ámbitos pero nunca hemos
tenido ingresos para traducir ese
potencial en acción ahora tenemos esos
ingresos si nos fijamos en la mitigación
tenemos 425 kilómetros de costa que
tenemos que asegurar estamos por debajo
del nivel del mar la subida del nivel
del mar está entre 12 y 21 pulgadas en
el resto del siglo eso es una proyección
de entonces solo mantener lo que tenemos
no construir nuevas defensas marítimas
solo mantener lo que tenemos nos costará
cerca de dos mil millones de dólares
21 youtube de ayudas todas todo este
petróleo se encuentra en la región del
esequibo que venezuela ha pedido en
disputa cuáles son los argumentos de
guyana en esta disputa territorial
en primer lugar no tenemos una disputa
sino una controversia tenemos muy claro
quiénes son nuestros aliados sin embargo
nos hemos embarcado en un viaje somos un
país que respete el estado de derecho
respetamos y honramos la libertad y la
paz somos un país que busca una
resolución pacífica ejercemos la
diplomacia y seguimos el curso de la
justicia este caso está ante la corte
internacional de justicia y nos atenemos
a las normas de la corte
y creemos que se resolverá y la corte
interamericana de justicia animará a
venezuela a participar en el proceso y a
formar parte de este sistema
internacional y a resolver este asunto
y cuáles son sus planes para la amazonía
no solo estamos protegiendo el medio
ambiente en la amazonía estamos
protegiendo nuestra selva para el mundo
nos hemos comprometido a una estrategia
de desarrollo con bajas emisiones de
carbono esa es nuestra vía de desarrollo
y esa vía de desarrollo incluye la
protección de la selva que es la más
grande del mundo lo he dicho antes
almacena 19 5 gigatoneladas de carbono
así que no porque estemos persiguiendo
nuestro sector del petróleo y el gas
estamos sacrificando nuestras
credenciales en materia de medioambiente
estamos trabajando en el fortalecimiento
de nuestras credenciales en materia de
medioambiente y en la construcción de
nuestro país en un camino sostenible
hacia una estrategia de desarrollo bajo
en carbono y tenemos la intención de
seguir haciéndolo pero no podemos
quedarnos de brazos cruzados y permitir
que no se valore el bosque que genera el
mayor nivel de biodiversidad además del
crédito del carbono y eso es parte de la
conversación que queremos tener aquí
también presidente como de su relación
con la oposición teniendo en cuenta que
hubo
parte y parte de ambos bandos
acusaciones de fraude
como saben estoy trabajando en gobierno
en una plataforma de william una guyana
significa que tenemos que traer a todo
el mundo a bordo what's up times
a people.com
es decir el mundo sabe que esta es una
oposición que trato de descarrilar la
democracia esta es una oposición que
trato de descarrilar el estado de
derecho una oposición que viene de una
industria de operar de esa manera los
años de dictadura en el país se
construyeron en este tiempo de oposición
así que lo que hemos estado buscando
está buscando tengo la responsabilidad
de todo eso y estoy separando el
comportamiento de la oposición de la
gente del país incluso si son
partidarios de la oposición porque mi
trabajo como presidente es trabajar para
atraer a todos los bienes es a bordo
extraer prosperidad para todos los
huilenses independientemente de quién
apoya políticamente y esa es mi agenda
construir una guyana de una manera
humilde construir una guyana de una
manera unificada y tomar todo eso con la
subida de la marea que vienen wanda
en un firewall antich en el hogar de
rising tide el escáner doctor mohamed
irfan al presidente de guyana muchas
gracias por su tiempo para france24
muchas gracias fue un placer estar aquí
y a ustedes muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión de en
exclusivo desde la ciudad de los ángeles
en eeuu
[Música]